so here we are in into Monday lots of
things are happening George papadopolis
Theodora Coppola snuffleupagus has
apparently cut a plea deal with the
special council we'll talk all about it
plus Paul Manafort Trump's former
campaign chairman is probably going to
go to jail and Kevin Spacey gives the
worst defense for allegedly attempting
to rape a child anyone has ever given
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show so much news so little time so
today it's a fun day because i get to
put on my lawyer head when I put on my
lawyer had it means that I'd go through
the full Paul Manafort indictment plus I
go through the special plea deal that
was cut by George Theodoric Apple Apple
ops nephal appleís we're gonna talk all
about that plus of course weíll get to
Kevin Spacey and the media being awful
at everything but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over a texture
so if you are addicted to information
the way that I am if you're constantly
on the go and looking for something to
read that is why you need to subscribe
to texture texture the app gives you
unlimited access to 200 premium
magazines
it has leading titles like time the
Atlantic The New Yorker Vanity Fair and
Wired and right now you can try texture
for free it is better than prints it
delivers unlimited access to over 200
premium magazines again it's going to
it's just great I mean I've gives you
the archives to all of these magazines
instead of you having to pay for a
separate subscription to each you're
paying a low fee to get 200 magazines
access complete access imagine having
all of your favorite magazines and their
back issues anytime anywhere that's what
texture does for a free trial go to
texture comm slash Ben again texture
comm slash Ben and then if you choose to
continue with texture podcast listeners
get texture for just $9.99 a month
that's $9.99 a month which is 30% off
they're listed price again if you
subscribe to like two magazines it's the
same price if you subscribe to 200
magazines you can do all that for $9.99
a month when you go to texture comm
slash Ben and try that free trial again
texture comm slash Ben to try the free
trial today and they're great gift
options available for the holiday season
makes a really good Christmas or
Hanukkah gift or Kwanzaa gift if that's
your thing or to Wally or whatever a
cultural holiday you're celebrating that
gives gifts texture calm is a good one
texture calm / Ben go check it out okay
so I don't know where to start because
there is so much news so we will start
from Paul manna for we'll start with
Paul manna for because this was the
expectation last week so as a recall on
it was announced that the special
counsel was going to drop indictments on
Monday I always love when they leave
cliffhangers at the end of a season it's
really exciting that way so they left
the cliffhanger on Friday who would be
indicted and everybody sort of assumes
it'll be manna for right it's gotta be
manna for because manna fort has been
known to be dirty for years and years
and years he was very very tied in with
the Republican establishment he really
was he was close to the bushes he was
close to the Republican National
Committee he was very close to a lot of
people in Republican halls of power I
know because I had heard of him sort of
in those circles but manna fort had also
been widely known since really 2012 to
sort of be a dirty character who was in
with the Ukrainian government who's
basically doing lobbying work allegedly
on behalf of the Ukrainian government
which is a Russian front puppet state
basically run by Ghana and Viktor
Yanukovych so the allegations in the
indictment the left was hoping that the
indictment would say Paul manna foreign
traded money in the Russians paid him in
order so that he would set up collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia
this is what the Democrats in the media
wanted they wanted Paul Manafort to be
the go-between for the supposed Russian
collusion that would show that Hillary
Clinton actually won the election except
for those scheming evil rule scenes okay
that's not what the indictment says the
indictment is 12 counts and basically
the entire thing is about how Paul
Manafort is a corrupt creep who was
taking money from this Ukrainian party
that was basically a front group for
Russia and then laundering it it's
pretty much the entire thing there's
nothing at Trump is not mentioned once
in the indictment the Trump campaign is
not mentioned one time in the indictment
virtually all of the bad acts happens in
2014 and before the in 2014 is when
Yanukovych left office so that cut off
sort of the money train for mana Ford
and then apparently he was still fibbing
about it and doing some money laundering
afterward but most of the bad activity
with regard to Russia at least as the
indictment says stops in 2014 so that's
the good news for Trump nothing in the
indictment suggests collusion between
Trump in the Russian government and
that's exactly what the Left wanted it
to say here's the bad news for Trump
metaphor is a crappy pick everyone knew
it at the time when manna fort was
picked people were immediately saying
this guy is probably gonna end up in
jail bad move by President Trump but it
shows you the level of chaos
that sort of predominated in the Trump
campaign in all likelihood somebody just
went to trump and said listen none of
them big campaign managers will work for
you here's this guy who's super
connected you know he has good business
connections Paul Manafort hire him and
so Trump went ahead
and hired him it's probably that simple
and that sort of chaos inside the Trump
administration also in my opinion could
easily explain the George papadopolis
routine that we're going to talk about
in just a little while so to finish up
with manna fort
basically the indictment alleges the
manna fort and Richard Gates the third
his right hands worked his quote
unregistered agents of the government of
Ukraine generated tens of millions of
dollars in income as a result of the
Ukraine work
they then laundered the money through
scores of u.s. and foreign corporations
partnerships and bank accounts manna
Fortin Gates allegedly did not register
as foreign agents which they apparently
were and then manna fort used his hidden
overseas wealth to enjoy a lavish
lifestyle in the United States without
paying taxes on income so basically
they're getting him for all the
financial impropriety it's between in or
around two thousand eight and two
thousand seventeen both dates being
approximate and inclusive according to
the indictment mana for ten gates
devised and intended to devise and
executed an attempted to execute a
scheme and artifice to defraud to obtain
money and property by means of false and
fraudulent pretenses representations and
promises from the United States bank and
other financial institutions allegedly
manna fort wired millions through other
companies for purposes of laundering so
if you saw Ozark basically he was Jason
Bateman and Ozark right essentially he
was just cleaning money except he was
cleaning it for himself apparently he
cleaned about eighteen million dollars
and seventy five million bucks passed
through his bank accounts no a lot of
the press is focused on this charge of
conspiracy against the United States
right in the indictment conspiracy
against the United States is now it
sounds like it's not a treason charge
it's not that he was treason ibly
committing offenses against the United
States to bring down the government or
to skew the election or anything like
that all conspiracy against the United
States means is there was a conspiracy
to break the laws of the United States
its financial charge based on two
frauding the US and covering it up
through alleged obstruction of justice
so the Amana Ford thing is a big nothing
as far as Trump is concerned unless of
course the idea here is to flip manna
fort against Trump right and that may be
the next step here one of the
assumptions here is that manna fort was
going to be tried in a state court so
that from couldn't pardon him the idea
being that then you could try and
leverage him to testify against
President Trump so before all of this
comes down over the weekend President
Trump starts tweeting out and again it
just shows you that Trump would be
better off being quiet and just letting
this stuff play out because if he's
really innocent then that will
be revealed in time and in fact it is
largely being revealed that nothing much
is happening here we'll get to as I say
this other plea deal in just a second
but Trump decides that it was absolutely
necessary to go on Twitter and so he
tweets out never seen such Republican
anger and unity as I have concerning the
lack of investigation on Clinton made
fake dossier now twelve million dollars
dot dot dot dot dot dot dot dot dot the
uranium to Russians yield the 33,000
plus deleted emails the Comey fixin so
much more instead they look at phony
Trump Russia dot dot dot dot dot dot dot
collusion which doesn't exist the Dems
are using this terrible and bad for our
country which hunts for evil politics
but the ours the meaning Republicans are
now fighting back like never before
there are so much guilt by Democrats
Clinton and now the facts are pouring
out do something like that's really how
he ends his tweet like all caps do
something so I could not help but
immediately flash the Spaceballs do
something do something I'm not sure what
exactly do something is supposed to mean
or why Trump is saying it he's the
President of the United States if he
wants to if he wants to tell his DOJ to
set up an investigation into Hillary
Clinton and her supposed collusion with
the Russians he can full well do it I
mean he has the power to do that the DOJ
works for him and obviously the DOJ
worked hand in glove with Obama so that
would not be outside his purview Trump
isn't doing that and so this sort of
like broad-stroke do something I just
don't know what that means do something
in all capital letters not useful and
makes Trump look more panicked than he
ought to be given the fact that there
really is no evidence of collusion at
least from the Manafort indictment Susan
Collins who's no ally to Trump right
Republican from Maine she says she's
seen no evidence of collusion I have not
yet seen any definitive evidence of
collusion I've seen lots of evidence
that the Russians were very active in
trying to influence the alleged okay so
again this is not really you know the
the idea that Trump should be panicked
at this point seems to me a little bit
ridiculous okay so that was the piece of
news number one piece of news number two
was this guy that I have been referring
to his name of course is george
papadapolis george papadapolis watching
stuff in a watchin snuffleupagus
with George Stephanopoulos eating
popcorn appleís with taki theodore
accomplice okay in any case I have too
much fun with his name George
papadopolis was a a low-level Trump
foreign policy advisor and he cut a plea
deal this was released at the same time
as the news about about Paul Manafort it
was released by the Muller team so this
one is a little more troubling for
president Trump the reason that it is
more troubling for President Trump is
not because it proves collusion between
Trump and Russia but because it tends
toward the idea that Trump and team
Trump were willing to collude with
Russia in order to do something hey we
already knew that Donald Trump jr.
months ago now released emails showing
that he was warm toward the idea of
receiving information about Hillary
Clinton from the Russian government has
quote part of their effort to aid Trump
in the election right so this is nothing
new but the media are gonna run with in
any way with the media are over reading
the Papadopoulos plea agreement now
number one it's important to note this
is a plea agreement with the FBI and the
reason that the plea agreement with the
FBI matters is presumably this guy is
ready to testify and maybe he's gonna
flip on other members of the campaign so
this one should be more troubling to
Trump because it's more likely to bleed
over into actual elements of the
campaign so I want to go through this
entire statement of offense what they
call statement of the offense which is
basically what Papadopoulos is admitting
to in order to avoid going to jail for a
long period of time so here is what is
excuse me here is what is alleged in
this statement of the offense okay so
the defendant george papadapolis who
served as a foreign policy advisor for
the presidential campaign of Donald J
Trump made material false statements and
material omissions during an interview
with the FBI that took place on January
27th 2017 at the time of the interview
the FBI had an open investigation into
the Russian government's efforts to
interfere in the 2016 presidential
election they accused Papadopoulos of
making material false statements and
material omissions to the FBI basically
what they accused is that so here's what
it says says defendant Papadopoulos
claimed that his interactions with an
overseas professor who defended
Papadopoulos understood to have
substantial connections to Russian
government officials occurred before
defendant Papadopoulos became a foreign
policy adviser to campaign that is not
true he acknowledged that the professor
had told him about the Russians
possessing dirt and then candidate
Hillary Clinton in the form of thousands
of emails but send many times he learned
the information prior to joining the
campaign
this is not true either had been told
that he was going to join the campaign
and in fact had joined the campaign so
then they presents a timeline of events
and I'm gonna go through this timeline
in just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over Red Seal
so does all of this news make you feel
like you could use a massage it makes me
feel like that if you feel like you
could use moments of relaxation amidst
the burning turmoil that is our news
cycle then you need to go over to zeal
download their app you can get a massage
basically on-demand at your house from a
professional licensed masseuse it's
fantastic I've used it my wife has used
it I've used it as a gift for my in-laws
for my parents for my sister you know it
really is tremendous it is the perfect
solution for anyone who wants a high
quality massage you don't want to drive
an hour to get there or wait in line at
a spa or have to make a reservation
instead they come to you they bring the
massage oils in the sense and the table
the whole deal it's just fantastic so go
to zeal comm or their zeal iPhone or
Android app Zeile spelled ze e L and
select from the most top local licensed
and pre-screened massage therapists
choose your favourite technique gender
preference time and location for your
massage seven days a week 365 a year a
zeal massage therapist can be at your
door and as little as an hour and they
have 9000 licensed masseuses we've tried
many of them they are all quite good to
help you get started our listeners can
get twenty five dollars off their first
massage by using the promo code been at
checkout again that's promo code been at
checkout and it gets better when you
sign up for the zeal massage membership
you get 20% off all your massages plus a
free massage table and sheet set which
is a $380 value yours free
there's no initiation fee to join the
membership just a great additional
savings on top of the $25 discount
you're gonna get when you use promo code
Bend so go to ze e Elcom or seals iPhone
or Android app make sure to clip add
promo code at checkout use promo code
Ben you get $25 off your first in-home
on-demand massage it's one of those
things that makes you feel wealthy even
if you are not it's it's a fantastic
service okay so let's go through the
timeline of Papadopoulos and the reason
we're gonna go through this timeline is
what we're going to show here is that
something we already know basically we
knew that there was willingness from
Team Trump to reach out to Russia for
dirt on Hillary Clinton now on the other
side which we'll get to in a second
Hillary Clinton's team apparently the
people who are working with Fusion GPS
were perfectly fine getting information
from the Russians about Trump so there's
a bit of a mirror image going on here
here's the time
so Papadopoulos learns in early March
2016 when it's becoming clear that Trump
is probably gonna win the nomination
that who'd be a foreign policy adviser
for the campaign he was living in London
at the time he then travelled over to
Italy and there he met a professor based
in London I do love how all of these
things are written up so that you don't
actually know who these people are I do
I do like that they call the professor
it sounds like it's Sherlock Sherlock
Holmes stories a Moriarty he meets a
professor based in London Professor
Moriarty seemed uninterested in the
defendant Papadopoulos until he found
out that Papadopoulos worked for the
campaign
at which point suddenly he was very
interested in Papadopoulos and
Papadopoulos was interested in the
professor because the professor claimed
to have substantial connections with
Russian government officials and
Papadopoulos thought that this could
increase his importance as a policy
advisor to the campaign so here is one
of the defense's that trump can use on
Papadopoulos stuff from the very
beginning it's pretty clear that a lot
of people in the Trump campaign knew
that Trump wanted to be warm toward the
Russians to be fair Trump was very clear
about this okay Trump went on the
campaign trail and talked about how he
liked Vladimir Putin and Putin was a
good guy and we've killed people too and
we should have a better relationship
with the Russians would that be the end
of the world it wasn't like Trump was
hiding the ball here he was saying all
this stuff publicly and so just as when
President Obama said wouldn't it be
great if someone cracked down on these
conservative 501 C 3s and then his IRS
wouldn't crack down on the conservative
501 C 3s it is quite possible to believe
that Trump was going out there saying we
should have a warm relationship with the
Russians and also Hillary Clinton is the
devil and a bunch of his lower down
people thought hey we can kill two birds
with one stone if we work with the
Russian government maybe they'll provide
us information on Hillary and we'll be
close with the Russians that'll be
awesome that's just what the boss wants
but it's quite possible that Trump never
instructed anybody to do any of this so
even if it turns out low-level members
of the Trump campaign or high-level
members of the Trump campaign we're
trying to collude it's possible that
doesn't go all the way to the top in
fact as I have been now claiming for a
year and a half I think that's very
unlikely that Trump knew about any sort
of collusion especially because if you
were going to collude with Russia in
illegal fashion would you tell the man
with the biggest mouth on planet earth
would that be your first choice doesn't
make a lot of sense okay in any case
around March 21st the campaign told The
Washington Post that Papadopoulos was
one of five named foreign policy
advisors for the campaign he then met
with the professor in London the
brought with him a female Russian
national the female Russian national as
she is known in this document introduced
to defendant Papadopoulos as a relative
of Vladimir Putin with connections to
senior Russian government officials so
who they're meeting with the Russians
okay here's the thing a lot of people in
a lot of campaigns meet with foreign
policy foreign policy members from other
countries so that in and of itself is
not criminal the question is whether the
foreign god is whether the the Trump
campaign was working with Russia to
subvert the election meeting with
somebody who's close to Putin does not
count okay
following the meeting the Papadopoulos
emailed the campaign supervisor we don't
know who this is this is why
Papadopoulos is important because after
he flips it's quite possible we're gonna
find out who campaign supervisor is
right who was supervising him at the
campaign and that may take us further up
the Trump chain and several members of
the campaign's foreign policy team and
said he met with his good friend the
professor who had introduced him to the
female Russian national who was
described as Putin's knees by
Papadopoulos as well as the Russian
ambassador in London Papadopoulos said
the topic of their discussion was to
arrange a meeting between us and the
Russian leadership to discuss US Russia
ties under President Trump so again this
is not necessarily illegal okay as
everyone has acknowledged campaigns meet
with foreign policy advisors from other
regimes all the time because you do want
to start figuring out what the
relationships gonna be like if in fact
your person is elected later apparently
Papadopoulos learned the female Russian
national was not a relative of President
Putin and he never actually met the
Russian ambassador in London he attended
a national security meeting in
Washington DC with Trump another foreign
policy adviser for the campaign when he
introduced himself to the group he said
that he had connections that he could
help arrange a meeting between Trump and
Putin okay again none of this is illegal
after that trip Papadopoulos worked with
the professor and female Russian
national to arrange a meeting between
the campaign and the Russian government
again none of this is illegal I keep
saying that because people are trying to
suggest that every meeting attempted to
be brokered between Trump and the
Russian government must have been about
Hillary Clinton this is untrue there is
not evidence of this even if
Papadopoulos was told by the Russians
that they wanted to funnel information
to the campaign it is not clear from
this document that the Trump campaign
took him up on that or even really
suggested a desire to take him up on
that
in April 2016 Papadopoulos and multiple
emails to other members of campaigns
foreign policy team regarding his
contacts with the Russians and his
outreach to Russia so we'll find out who
those people are I am sure and then the
the key the key provision here happens
on April 24th or April 28th April 26th
rather okay here it is on or about April
26th Papadopoulos met the professor for
breakfast at a London hotel
up till now they'd only been talking
about Trump meeting with the Russians or
from people meeting with the Russians
but nothing about actually passing dirt
on Hillary Clinton here is the key
moment on or about April 26 2016
defendant Papadopoulos met the professor
for breakfast at a London hotel during
this meeting the professor told
defendant Papadopoulos he'd just
returned from a trip to Moscow where he
admit with high-level Russian government
officials the professor told defendant
Papadopoulos that on that trip the
professor learned the Russians had
obtained dirt right in quotes and then
candidate Clinton the professor told
Papadopoulos as Papadopoulos later
described to the FBI
the Russians have dirt on her the
Russians had emails of Clinton they have
thousands of emails so it is unclear
number one so people are saying well
this happened in late April March is
when WikiLeaks or whomever attacked the
DNC and and got all the emails out of
the DNC it is not clear that the emails
they were describing here are those
emails it's quite possible they're
talking about the 33,000 emails that
Hillary had deleted and maybe the
Russian government had hacked into her
server when she had a private server in
her bathroom okay so all of that being
the case now we know the Russian
government is trying to funnel
information to the Trump campaign so
what happens after that
following the count in that conversation
Papadopoulos continued to correspond
with campaign officials continue to
communicate with the professor and the
Russian MFA connection in an effort to
arrange a meeting between the campaign
and the Russian government again it is
not clear it is not clear that these
meetings necessarily have to do with
passing Hillary information and this is
an important question if the meetings
were just about Trump meeting with
Russian people big deal if the meetings
were about Trump meeting with Russian
people to coordinate election efforts
that is a big deal okay but again that
evidence is still lacking at this point
we'll have to wait for more evidence to
come out Papadopoulos shared information
from the MFA connection apparently he
said that they were open for cooperation
and again it's not clear what
cooperation means at one point the the
government notes that the official
forwarded a Papadopoulos email to
another campaign official instead of
quote let's discuss this about having a
meeting let's discuss we need someone to
communicate that DT Donald Trump is not
doing these trips it should be someone
low level in the campaign so as not to
send any signal okay so there's two ways
to read that one is Trump wants to
coordinate with the Russians and he
wants to send someone low level to do it
so it doesn't reach Trump the other way
to read that is that they're just trying
to brush Papadopoulos off right they're
saying to Papadopoulos you have no power
get out of here we don't care about you
and someone low level in the campaign
should should tell him that Trump is not
doing these trips so as not to send any
signal that Trump himself doesn't want
to do the trips to the Russians but just
you know basically brush Papadopoulos
off in any case what comes out from all
of this what is the final statement the
final point from all of the Papadopoulos
stuff is that basically the the
situation shows that the Trump campaign
as we already knew was willing to work
with the Russians or at least members of
the Trump campaign were willing to work
with the Russians to take down Hillary
Clinton did they actually do it unclear
but we already knew that from the Donald
Trump jr. letters we already knew that
from the Donald Trump jr. emails so
nothing new Under the Sun the media are
blowing this out of proportion
we're gonna have to wait to see where
this goes from here but there's no
question that the Papadopoulos stuff is
much more damaging to the Trump campaign
than it is to the then is the Manta fort
stuff then it is in the matter of force
stuff so I want to talk about the latest
on the Clinton dossier and what that
means because now we have basically two
parallel stories we have the Trump
attempting to collude with the Russians
story which may or not be real and then
we have the Hillary attempting to
collude with the Russian story which may
or may not be real a lot of this seems
like smoke a lot of it seems like not
fire but I'm going to explain all that
in just a second first I want to say
thank you for sponsors over at my
Patriot supply so if you are looking at
the world scene and thinking an
emergency is quite possible right
whether it's a wildfire or an earthquake
whether it's a tornado or hurricane when
you look at all of that and you say to
yourself there may be a situation where
I can't get to the grocery store for a
couple of days what should I do
right I have a family to feed this is
why you need to go over to my friends
and my Patriots applying it they're 102
serving survival food kit for just 99
bucks it includes breakfast lunches
dinner's it shipped to your home for
free order a kits here for yourself
right now call eight eight eight eight
oh three fourteen thirteen that's eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen or go online and prepare with
pens calm the emergency food lasts up to
25 years in storage people the office of
tried at they say it tastes like home
cooking the best time to prepare is
before there's some sort of emergency
obviously the government recommends you
have this sort of food supply on hand
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen or prepare with been
calm again prepare with been calm eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen for your one hundred and two
servings survival food kit for just 99
bucks breakfast lunches and dinners it's
a one-time investment and you're not
gonna regret it
because honestly the only way to regret
it is if nothing bad happens in your
life which would be great and if
something bad does happen they're gonna
be happy that you prepared okay so well
all of this is happening the Clinton
dossier stuff continues to blow up so
one of the sort of accusations here is
that if things get too bad for Trump on
the Trump Russia stuff then eventually
he's just gonna order his DOJ to look in
to investigate Hillary Clinton and the
Trump Oppo research project so here's
what we know again about to recap about
the Trump Apple research project from
the Clinton team so Clinton team went to
fusion GPS a democratic firm and they
paid them apparently millions and
millions of dollars apparently paid a
law firm write this law firm is a major
law firm so not every dollar spent at
the law firm went to fusion GPS I used
to work at a major law firm called
Goodwin Proctor it had you know dozens
and dozens of branches all over the
country just because you use Goodwin
Proctor doesn't mean that any specific
area where Goodwin Proctor was funneling
money meant that you were paying that
place right good and Proctor was bigger
than the places that it was spending
money but the same thing is true of the
of the law firm that Hillary Clinton's
team was paying in any case they spent
millions of dollars on this law firm and
then apparently some of those millions
were passed on infusion GPS for this
Apple Research thing okay the Apple
Research thing ends up being the steel
dossier Christopher Steele former mi6
spy he goes over to Russia he talks a
bunch of Russian officials and he comes
back with a dossier some of the things
in the dossier have been debunked some
of the things in the dossier have not
been debunked for people who say that
it's been debunked that is not true some
things have been debunked some things
have not been debunked the big question
here is did Hillary Clinton and her team
know that the steel dossier was filled
with Russian Intel did they know that
the steel dossier was filled with
references to direct government
officials in Russia now they're people
on the left you say
well there's a difference between
Hillary digging up dirt on Trump's
dealings with Russia and Trump dealing
up to digging up dirt from Russia about
Hillary's dealings not with Russia
I think there's there may be something
to that but I don't think that it fixes
the generalized problem which is if
Hillary Clinton is complaining about
Russian interference in the election and
about Trump coordination with the
Russians then going to the Russians for
help against Trump
both undercuts that narrative and
demonstrates that your own team was
willing to work with the Russian
government if they could dig something
up about then-candidate Trump so Jeanine
Pirro is leading the charge a lot of
Republicans are already in sort of
defensive mode despite the fact that the
Mueller investigation hasn't come up
with anything really serious yet they're
already in defensive mode and they're
suggesting that Trump go on offense
against Hillary Clinton again I think
Hillary Clinton should be fully
investigated I think all of this should
have a full investigation but to suggest
that you know the the main line of
attack right now should be about Hillary
Clinton and when nothing really bad is
happening from a Muller investigation
seems to me like revving up the engine
while you're still in neutral so here's
Jeanne Moreau saying it's time to lock
Hillary up it's time to shut it down
turn the tables and lock her up that's
what I said
I actually said it lock her up well she
said it and since she said it I guess we
have to do it Obama's and the Clintons
built the Trump Russia connection
collapsed yesterday when it was
disclosed that the Clinton campaign and
the DNC paid 12 million dollars for a
dossier to connect Donald Trump to
Russia
okay we can stop that there so here's
the the problem with this again
Hillary's malfeasance doesn't justify
Trump's malfeasance both of them seem to
have been willing to engage in something
right it looks like the the Clinton
campaign actually engaged in something
right the idea that the Clinton team
didn't know the millions of dollars were
being funneled for a dossier and what
the dossier included I find highly
suspicious so what we have here I said
this online and people on the right one
nuts okay what I said was basically what
we have in the last election cycle were
two teams of people who were willing to
collude with the other side meaning
Russia in order to get their opponent
okay that much is true then people said
well Hillary was worse because Hillary
actually colluded
the seal dossier okay that may be true
I'm not denying that but just because
both sides were willing to conclude and
only one side was capable of finishing
the collusion that does not actually
mean that both sides are good or that
one side is good now people can say
Trump is better than Clinton maybe in
the same way that I guess
attempted-murder is better than actual
murder if we're talking about crimes
here but I still don't think that that
really meets the standard of decency
this I guess goes back to the last
election cycle when I said that both
candidates can suck people have a tough
time with that but the reality is that
what we're seeing from Team Trump well
we don't see criminal activity yet from
Team Trump with regard to Russia
collusion the idea that they're willing
to collude with Russia has been known
since the Donald Trump jr. emails and
those emails were not good for Team
Trump right it was kind of scuzzy I mean
if you're willing to work with the
Russians in order dig up Trump dirt on
Hillary that's not good and the fact
that Hillary was willing to have
somebody take up dirt on Trump from the
Russians is also not good it's possible
that everyone sucks and that one is
worse both things can be true at once
well the Democrats are still trying to
focus in on on this dossier - and trying
to say the dossier contains damning
material about Trump Adam Schiff who's
this representative Democrat from from
California he says that the dossier has
still not been debunked and they're
still krazee-eyez Adam jeff says that
it's most important is to determine what
is true in the dossier I certainly would
have you know like to know who paid for
it earlier but nonetheless that's just
one factor to be considered it doesn't
answer the ultimate question which is
how much of the work is accurate how
much of it is true and my colleagues
don't seem particularly interested in
that question but that is really the
most important question for the American
people that is how much of this
allegation that Christopher steel makes
and the reports that he hears are true
about the Russian government wanting to
help the Trump campaign now so a couple
of things one there are two things that
are worth investigating one what's in
the dossier is true and two did Hillary
Clinton work with the Russians in order
to compile a dossier about her opponent
right I mean that is it that is bad
stuff okay so I do want to talk about
Kevin Spacey at length because this is
an amazing story and it demonstrates the
full-on politically correct insanity of
the left a political correct leftism
that eats its own but first you're gonna
have to go over and subscribe at daily
wire comm so for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe over at daily wire that means
you get
rest of my show on video for free live
it means that you can also later
download the show and you can get it
without commercials which is pretty
awesome also you get the website without
any banner ad which is pretty great also
you get Andrew Clavin show live on video
you get you get Michael Moses show live
on video complete you get all of those
things for $9.99 a month for $99 a year
you get all of those things plus you get
this leftist here's hot or cold tumblr
the greatest of all beverage vessels
containing the the tears of your
political opponents as well as other
liquids that are probably more drinkable
and more sanitary so make sure that you
get that tumbler because for 99 bucks
it's a better deal than actually getting
the monthly subscription go over and
subscribe over to our channel at
youtube.com as well subscribe to our
channel because we have lots of video
content that comes out on a regular
basis you're gonna want to subscribe by
the way because tomorrow's shows gonna
be tons of fun also because tomorrow is
Halloween and we actually do do
Halloween on the bench Shapiro shows
we're gonna be doing something fun that
we have planned for tomorrow / later
today so that would should be fun also
make sure you go over and check out
iTunes or SoundCloud subscribe leave us
a review it always helps and we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing podcast in the nation
[Music]
I should say conservative podcast in the
nation sometimes I leave out the
conservative in any case okay let's talk
about Kevin Spacey for just a second
because this is an amazing story so over
the weekend these allegations come out
from BuzzFeed that a an actor named
Anthony Rapp who was on Broadway at the
time was 14 years old this is 31 years
ago I guess and he was 14 years old and
Kevin Spacey who has won two Oscars was
apparently at a party with this kid 14
year old kid and picked him up
like Rhett Butler with Scarlett O'Hara
picked him up put him on a bed and then
attempted to climb on top of him I have
14 year old kids he's attempting to
sexually assault a 14 year old kid so
Kevin Spacey comes out and here is his
statement as hey comes out I mean like
in a couple of ways so he comes out and
here is his statement Kevin Spacey he
says quote I have a lot of respect and
admiration for Anthony Rapp as an actor
I'm beyond horrified to hear his story I
honestly do not remember the encounter
it would have been over 30 years ago but
if I did behave then as he describes I
owe him the sincerest apology for what
would have been deeply inappropriate
drunken behavior and I am sorry for the
feelings he describes having carried
with him all these years and this story
has encouraged me to address other
things about my life I know there are
stories out there about me and that some
have been fueled by the fact I've been
so protective of my privacy as those
closest to me know in my life I've had
relationships with both men and women I
have loved and had romantic encounters
with men throughout my life and I choose
now to live as a gay man I want to deal
with this honestly and openly and that
starts with examining my own behavior so
this is what we call the Jim McGreevey
defense I don't know if you remember all
the way back to 2004 okay for those of
in our younger in our audience in 2004
there was a New Jersey Governor his name
was Jim McGreevey Jim McGreevey was a
Democrat and his second is his I guess
chief of staff or security chief accused
Jim McGreevey of sexually harassing him
and Jim McGreevey was married got a kid
right he'd married twice and he had two
kids and Jim McGreevey released a long
weepy statement about how he was a gay
man I German greevey are I am a gay man
and the media said oh what a hero oh
what a good guy you know doesn't matter
that he cheated on his wife with men
doesn't matter that he was sexually
harassing a guy the important thing is
that he was gay he was gay he played the
gay card right in much the same way that
the media have totally overlooked
you know the the traffic accident that
killed somebody the Caitlyn Jenner was
involved in because Caitlyn Jenner is a
hero because Caitlyn Jenner's
transgender this is the routine that we
do now in America is that if you are if
you are involved in an alleged crime if
you come out as gay or if you show your
proper lefty bonafide ease then we sort
of ignore it right the only reason that
Harvey that's why Harvey Weinstein his
initial response to the sexual assault
the rape charges that were being made
about him was I'm gonna target the NRA
he was hoping to buy off the left media
so the question that I had last night
reading this was was this going to work
because there are a couple problems for
Kevin Spacey here one is everyone's
known that he's gay for at least 20
years I mean I remember growing up there
were open jokes in Hollywood about Kevin
Spacey being gay in fact there were open
jokes about Kevin Spacey molesting
children and Family Guy famously made
fun of Kevin Spacey like 10 years ago
when in a scene in which Stewie Wright
the baby is running naked through a mall
and shouting I just escaped from Kevin
Spacey's basement so these allegations
been made about Kevin Spacey for years
and years and years behind closed doors
that's problem number one for Kevin
Spacey problem number two is that the
gay community has tried very very hard
to separate off the allegations that
homosexuality is associated with
pedophilia they spent years trying to
say homosexuality is not pedophilia
pedophilia is unacceptable and malo
station of children is unacceptable and
trying to suggest that being gay is
associated with pedophilia is a form of
homophobia right this is the claim that
the left has made for years that the the
LGBT community has made for years this
pretty much undermines that case at
least from Spacey's point of view right
because the shorter defense here is sure
I may have tried to molest a
fourteen-year-old boy but I'm gay that
is not a good defense that is not a good
line of defense you know morally or for
the gay community which is attempting to
say it is not appropriate to do this
right the gay community was angry when
my Logan op Allah suggested that it was
fine that he was molested as a child by
a priest and when all of this stuff
comes out in the gay community people
tend to say well that those are isolated
incidents that's not indicative of a
trend well this does not help that
particular case right so Kevin Spacey
undermining the legitimacy of the
homosexual community that is not
involved in pedophilia by basically
linking what he did to Anthony Rapp with
with being gay right the main part of
the Anthony Rapp story the people found
disturbing was not the
the gay stuff it was the fact that Kevin
Spacey was attempting to molest a child
Raymond 14 years old as a child his
one-year pastor Bar Mitzvah you really
it's amazing stuff so how the question
is how do the media responds well I
asked this last night would the media
buy into the idea that Kevin Spacey was
a hero and let him off easy because he
now says he's gay so this is the
intersectional politics of the left if
you are gay or you're black or you're
Hispanic or you're a woman if you make
the claim that whatever you did wrong is
based on your victimization as a member
of that community can you get away with
it this is always the intersectional
question and so I asked this last night
and a bunch of people I'm Watson no no
way he gets away with this no way the
media will the media won't fall for this
the media won't say that the headline is
that he's gay the media will say the
headline is that he's basically quasi
acknowledging he may have tried to rape
a fourteen-year-old uh-uh uh-uh here's
the headline from Reuters quote actor
Kevin Spacey declares he lives life as a
gay man if I read you that statement
would that be your headline whether
headline be I was drunk Kevin Spacey
admits to quasi admits to drunkenly
attempting to have sex with a 14 year
old boy or what the headline be Kevin
Spacey says he lives life as a gay man I
mean is that a cover-up of epic media
proportions or what here's the headline
from ABC News I choose to live as a gay
man Kevin Spacey comes out in emotional
tweet emotional tweet for God's sake he
came out because a guy a guy accused him
of trying to molest him when he was 14
years old this is insanity now there are
many media outlets that are reporting
both facts right there saying things
like after accusations of sexual
molestation Spacey comes out as gay
right but again if the if the punch line
is Spacey comes out as gay you're
missing the punch line the punch line is
Spacey trying to fob off molesting a
fourteen-year-old by saying he was drunk
at the time
I don't remember everybody being you
know quite so accepting of Roman
Polanski raping a 13 year old girl right
maybe he should have just ripped the
thirteen-year-old boy and then said that
he was drunk at the time and gay I mean
this is insanity
this is fully insanity and again this is
not good for the LGBT community for
people who are saying well you know we
have to be protective of his rights as a
gay man no you have to be protective of
the rights of children and gay people
understand this I mean that's been the
response that I've seen from the LGBT
folks that I know online right the gay
people I'm seeing online are saying this
is insane how could Kevin Spacey say
such a thing how can Kevin Spacey
our entire case like this the media
cheering Spacey is just another
indicator that the media are really
disgusting and they're left ISM
overcomes even their most basic sort of
moral stances okay time for some things
I like and some things I hate then I've
decided to initiate something new on
Mondays on Mondays I think that we're
going to start going through some
founding documents because I think it's
important for people to really
understand found in philosophy so we
have Big Idea Thursdays that's not
always about the founding and I think
what I want to do is go through one of
the federalist papers every week so that
by the end of a year and a half or two
we will have gone through the entirety
of the Federalist Papers and you will
know what exactly our founding fathers
had to say about our system of
government which i think is super
important so time for things I like in
things I hate first then we will get to
that so things I like let's do it so we
begin with a last week somebody asked
about my favorite parenting books books
that I like about parenting so this is
one that is really good for when you
have toddlers so toddlers are the worst
people in the world
okay toddlers I listen I love my
daughter she is spectacular she is just
the love of my life
we have the best relationship she's
she's sweet as honey she's just
wonderful she's smart as a whip she's so
smart like the other day she actually
defined for me onomatopoeia seriously
she's three and a half she's she's got
she's just a wonderful kid but like any
other Tabler toddlers are little
monsters okay and toddlers do not have
any prefrontal cortex development which
means anything they are thinking comes
right out so that doesn't just mean they
say it cute innocent things it also
means they scream like banshees when
they don't get what they want they fuss
they will try to hit people
studies show them between two and three
is the most violent time of human beings
life as a general matter and so the
first thing that you have to debunk as a
parent is the idea that your child is
naturally good your child is not
naturally good your child is naturally a
child and children are naturally
terrible right this is why they have to
be civilized
John Roseman is sort of a more
traditional parenting expert I know John
a little bit I've known him for years he
wrote a book called the well-behaved
child discipline that really works the
whole book is basically about how there
must be consequences when children
misbehave so I know it's super painful
it really is as a parent it's painful
for me to punish my child really painful
like she does something and it's quasi
cute but also kind of malicious and I
don't want to punish her I don't I don't
like seeing her suffer and also I like
doing fun things with her so I wanted to
pride myself of that play yes you do you
want to say to her you're not allowed to
do X
and if you do X then the rule is you're
not getting Y right and you have to be
very strict about it and you have to be
very consistent about it and it doesn't
matter if they cry it doesn't matter if
they apologize even if they apologize
and they fix the behavior whatever you
said the punishment will be has to be
fulfilled otherwise the child is
learning to manipulate you not to
actually be good the book is the
well-behaved child by John Roseman it's
really really useful for parents who are
having trouble with toddlers which is to
say every parent who's ever had a
toddler so check that out other things
that I like so
last week in Congress there is a hearing
about the the fact that in Europe there
is so much abortion of people who are
Down syndrome or mentally ill in the
womb or have damaged in the womb and
this it was an amazing moment that in
Frank Stevens the Down syndrome guy who
is testifying on the hill about the
situation in Europe and here's what he
had to say about about abortion of the
of the Down syndrome children let me say
that I am NOT a a a research scientist
however no one knows more about life
what Down syndrome then than I do
whatever whatever you learn today please
remember this I am a man with Down
syndrome and my life is worth living
okay and the left doesn't seem to
acknowledge this is why they say things
like well theof the down syndrome baby
wouldn't it better for the be better for
the kid not to live it no it would not
be better for the kid not to live life
is always a better choice okay time for
a couple of things I hate then we'll get
to Federalist number one
so John Kasich says he wants to run for
president again oh no God no please no
sweet baby Jesus no not John Kasich
please no God no that's my basic
commentary on that Kasich wants to run
for president again after his dramatic
fail of a run in 2016 when he stayed in
just long enough to ensure that
President Trump would actually become
the nominee in the first place
Kasich is one of the more insufferable
people in the political scene he
portrays himself as this high-and-mighty
guy basically he just thinks the
government should be used for his own
personal predilections which is quite
despicable and and Kasich running is
just another vanity campaign no I would
not vote for John Kasich in a primary
John Kasich is is awful okay other
things that I hate so Democrat senator
Kamala Harris is now accusing the
Justice Department of siding with
discrimination why because the DOJ has
basically suggested that it is not going
to it's not gonna crack down hard on
private companies that discriminate
against LGBT people or LGBT behavior so
she did a dinner at the Human Rights
Campaign and she said that attorney
general session stands on the side of
discrimination against equality here's
what she said LGBT rights are under
attack
under attack by a Justice Department
that now stands on the side of
discrimination instead of equality under
attack by a Senate nominee who thinks
homosexuality should be illegal and a
judicial nominee who says transgender
children are proof of Satan's plan and
under attack by a commander-in-chief who
wants to ban transgender troops who are
willing to sacrifice their lives to
defend our country okay so there are a
few things that I hate about this one
the implication that the DOJ has a role
in policing private business as a
general matter I object to object to
this on every level I cut an entire
video about it actually that you can
view over a YouTube about why the
government needs to be involved in
preventing private discrimination I have
problems with this so should Kamala
Harris because if she wants any
Christians to be able to go into any gay
bake shop and have them make an anti-gay
cake then she should continue along
these lines because that's exactly where
she is going now as far as Roy Moore
right he's a Senate candidate from
Alabama Roy Moore says really nutty
things there are some things about Roy
Moore that I've liked for example I
actually don't object to Roy Moore
bucking against the federal judiciary as
the sort of final authority on the
Constitution however what Roy Moore has
said about Muslims not being allowed to
serve in Congress is absurd while Remora
has said about homosexuality being
illegal is absurd right all of that is
absurd basically in Alabama you
basically have the 2016 election all
over again there are a lot of people who
are voting for Roy Moore in order to
stop whoever the Democrat is from taking
that particular office but in any case
when Kamala Harris does this routine
like LGBT people are under assault from
the Trump administration that is just
not true and when she says you know
transgenders serving in the military you
know there's no case for those people
not being able to serve in the military
a she's a pretty strong case for people
who suffer from severe mental illness
not to serve in the military there are
lots of people who don't get to serve in
the military serving the military is not
a right serving in the military is is a
privilege and the fact that people want
to in now that can volunteer for the
military and it's not a draft the fact
that you know people want to serve but
can't is nothing new there are lots of
people who want to serve but can't and
again it creates all sorts of issues
have been talking with people in the
military
been telling me about the education that
they're being forced to go through with
regard to transgender troops it openly
says in those in those transgender
training sessions that a man who
identifies as a woman should be allowed
to shower with the woman in the barracks
I mean this is not good or easy stuff
okay other things that I hate final
thing I hate then we'll get to the
Federalist Papers so john bainer did an
interview with Politico in which he laid
into every Republican he could think up
he laid into george w bush he laid into
Ted Cruz he laid into Mark Levin he laid
into pretty much everything on the right
side of the aisle Jim Jordan the
congressman from Ohio he said eff Jim
Jordan eff jason Chaffetz he said Jordan
was a terrorist as a legislator going
back to his days in the Ohio House and
Senate a terrorist a legislative
terrorist is it any wonder we got rid of
Boehner is it any wonder that we got
Donald Trump that people looked at the
establishment and said they are so much
more willing to attack people on their
own side than they are willing to attack
the left right he actually defends Obama
in this right here's something John
Boehner says remember this was the
Speaker of the House for Republicans
quote people thought in Oh 9 10 11 the
country couldn't be divided more and go
back to Obama's campaign in 2008 you
know he was talking about the divide and
healing the country and all of that
and some would argue on the right he did
more to divide the country than to
United I kind of reject that notion
it was modern-day media and social media
that kept people pushing further right
and further left people started to
figure out they could choose where to
get their news I always liked Rush
Limbaugh when I went to Palm Beach I
would always meet with Rush and we'd go
play golf but you know who is that
right-wing guy Mark Levin he really went
crazy right and got a big audience and
he dragged Hannity to the dark side he
dragged rush to the dark side and these
guys I used to talk to them all the time
and something they're beating the living
bleep out of me I wasn't gonna be a
right-wing idiot can you imagine why
perhaps the conservative base might have
been unhappy with John Boehner who
repeatedly cut deals with President
Obama repeatedly repeatedly and then he
blames the right-wing base maybe you
should have been better at your job dude
okay now I want to go very quickly
through Federalist number once the
Federalist Papers have the greatest set
of discussions on the foundation of a
government in human history
they are fantastic the first one was
written by Alexander Hamilton so this
were all written in the New York papers
by Publius Publius was a pen name for
John J Alexander Hamilton and James
Madison so some of them are written by
Jay Syme Overton by Madison some written
by Hamilton Federalist number one was
written by Alexander Hamilton who is the
flavor of the month now because there's
a musical about him so here is what he
talked about what he says and this is
the part that I found really
knitting what he says is I'm not going
to impugn the intentions of people who
oppose the Constitution and it's
something we should remember now I'm not
gonna limp youn them because that would
not help me convince them he says where
they're not even these inducements to
moderation nothing could be more
ill-judged nothing could be more
ill-judged than that intolerant spirit
which has at times characterized
political parties for in politics as in
religion it is equally absurd to aim at
making proselytes by fire and sword
heresies in either can rarely be cured
by persecution rights there he is making
the case for religious toleration and
also political toleration understand
that your political opponent may not
have bad intent Kamala Harris describes
bad intent maybe your political opponent
just disagrees and you're not going to
win them over by claiming it they're a
bunch of Nazis when I say that the left
says that they're a bunch of Nazis okay
I have to show you this commercial
briefly this is from a Latino group
that's now running in the Virginia
governor's race against Ed Gillespie the
Republican okay when I say that the left
assumes that the right has bad
intentions that they're all deplorable
and evil look at this commercial this is
an insane commercial but it does the
precise opposite of what Hamilton is
talking about in Federalist number one
okay so you see all these minority
children who are running around and then
there's a minority kid who's running
from a truck that has confederate flag
on the back right some white guy some
evil white guy with a confederate rug on
the back confederate flag on the back
okay to his looks like a Hispanic kid
and now there's an Asian kid and they
both start running for their lives and
on the back of the truck it says it
Gillespie for governor and now there's a
Muslim kid and there's a black head and
they all start running from this truck
clearly this truck with the Ed Gillespie
sticker and the and the Confederate flag
wants to run them down and murder them
because it's a white supremacist with
the don't tread on me flag on the on the
front of the car chasing after them
they've all runs the fence and then the
the trucks can crush them and all these
kids wake up from the nightmare is this
what Donald Trump and Ed Gillespie mean
by the American dream Latino victory fun
Pete and then it's and then it's and
then it shows the march from
Charlottesville just despicable just
despicable Ed Gillespie condemned that
March and go has to be opposed that
March he opposes the white supremacist
it's just disgusting so that you present
you want to know why the
country's coming apart because of what
Hamilton talks about in federal that's
number one being ignored
he finished his Federalist number one by
saying something else that's a value he
says history will teach us that he
basically says we should make the case
for reason government based on what
government will work best
rather than shouting about rights of the
people right we have this rights talk
that now predominates in American
government where people on the right say
all of our rights are gonna be violated
we're all gonna be murdered and people
on the Left saying all of your rights
are gonna be violated you're gonna be
starved without big government he says
history will teach us that the former
has been found a much more certain roads
to the introduction of despotism than
the latter meaning broad appeals to the
rights of the people and that those of
those of the men that that of those men
who have overturned the liberties of
Republic's the greatest number have
begun their career by paying an
obsequious court to the people
commencing demagogues and ending tyrants
right they begin as demagogues they and
his tyrants why because they appeal to
the people right like bein in in Dark
Knight Rises they appeal to the people
and then they're able to gather they
will about them in order to go and do
bad things so Federalist number one a
good introduction to how political
debate should be done in America and
Alexander Hamilton was you know in it
with the best of them so check that out
we'll be back here tomorrow for more I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]